there we go good afternoon thank you
for coming gotcha
yeah so as ill and explained I'm a
refugee from mathematical academia and
about five years ago I turned to data
science and machine learning where I've
been working for the same company
lateral doing machine learning for text
applications but there's there's nothing
corporate about today's talk it's
supposed to be a fun introduction to
machine learning from a slightly
different perspective so why don't I
begin by motivating the fun side it's
cool so what I'm going to talk about is
solving very simple substitution ciphers
where you replace letters to make
messages unreadable with an algorithm
and one reason this is cool is because
it's going to turn out to be machine
learning but from a slightly different
perspective so typically in machine
learning applications for example if you
have a neural network you're optimizing
over a continuous space a very high
dimensional real vector space for
example and you're doing something like
gradient descent here it'll turn out
that the parameter space over which
we're optimizing is discrete precisely
because it's the set of alphabets that
encode messages so that's one
interesting difference from a typical
machine learning application but from an
applied perspective it's also cool and
one of the reasons it's cool is because
there still exists undeciphered really
old manuscripts that historians are
interested in and would love to read
that can't so possibly the most famous
of these is the Voynich manuscript named
after a guy called Wilfrid Voynich who
originally came from Poland born in the
latter half of the 19th century went via
Siberia to London ended up in New York
as a rare book server of all things got
his hand on this manuscript via his wife
no one could read it he couldn't sell it
he eventually donated to Yale and we
figured out in the meantime that it's
very old it dates back to the early
1400s and no one knows anything about it
it looks like it's kind of a natural
script
it could be deliberately in ciphered it
could be an example of a forgotten
language or it could be a known language
in an unfamiliar alphabet nothing is
known about this whatsoever
so having got you as as excited
I am I hope let oh by the way there's
it's it's not just text there are some
cool illustrations there as well so we
see things that look like sunflowers
there's a picture of what looks like
Roman Baths there on the right
nonetheless the pictures don't don't
seem to help people be able to decipher
it okay it's a very cool problem but I'm
going to begin with a disclaimer so
first of all the version of this problem
I'm going to solve is a toy problem it's
nothing like as ambitious as decrypting
arbitrary historical texts and so the
the assumptions that go into the machine
learning algorithm will be artificially
simple just to make it tractable it's
begin a talk and secondly as a result
it's not original research in any way so
here's what's going to happen first of
all I'm going to introduce some notation
and define some stuff secondly on the
basis of that we can frame the problem
precisely to a degree of precision that
a computer can solve with machine
learning thirdly I'll say okay what is a
naive solution look like
how would you sort of try and do this at
first and that will form a sort of
skeleton pseudo algorithm on which I put
meat later when I talk about the maths
and stats tools that are necessary to
fish that out and lastly I'll turn the
naive solution into a proper algorithm
that I'll go through step-by-step with
you so we're talking about encryption
and decryption what is that I'm going to
take a very naive examples based
explanation we have plain text on the
left which humans can read and
encryption and decryption the inverse
processes which take plaintext to
ciphertext unreadable text and back so a
very simple example the cat sat on the
mat I'm going to map t - u + H - I and E
to F and so on and I think maybe you've
got the pattern by now and that's going
to be my cypher text so in general with
encryption and decryption you've got to
do two things - to choose an encryption
scheme you've got to first of all choose
an algorithm so in this case it's a
monoalphabetic substitution cipher or
mask for sure and that's just the
algorithm in which I replace each
plaintext letter
with a single fixed ciphertext error
it's as simple as you can imagine so
that's the algorithm and then the
details of that algorithm which letters
in particular well that's called the key
so here I've got the encryption and
decryption keys they are of course
reverses of each other a goes to be an
encryption scheme and then B goes back
to a with decription so because there
are two components to a cipher scheme
encrypting and decrypting involved two
choices in general you've got to choose
your algorithm then choose ek or deduce
those if you're going in Reverse so just
to highlight the important stuff here so
I've got this word monoalphabetic
substitution cipher which just means
replacing single plaintext letters with
cipher text correspondence they called
masks and that's the only kind of cipher
I will talk about for the rest of this
talk so let me frame the problem now and
I'll begin by writing down some
assumptions so the first of these is
artificially let's assume that we've
been given ciphertext by an enemy but we
know that it's encrypted by one of these
simple masks so just exchanging letters
secondly I'm going to assume that we
have enough ciphertext I've put it in
scare quotes because I haven't defined
it but that will be in a suitable
statistical sense that I'll expand on
later and thirdly I want the punctuation
to be stripped from the plaintext just
to make things simple and importantly
I'm going to specify that the spaces
between the words are preserved
that's because it'll turn out to be
important what the patterns of
characters are within words themselves
and we need to know the boundaries so
lastly and this is this is also
applicable to the machine learning
assumption I'm going to assume that we
know the source language very artificial
so totally unlike the Voynich manuscript
so we know for example that it's written
in English even though we can't read it
and therefore we have access to two
texts from the source language not
exactly the text that we're looking for
that would be cheating but to any other
sample of text we might care to find
what are the consequences of these
assumptions that help us well first of
all one and two just make the problem
feasible if we don't have enough text we
can't solve it and I don't want to be
iterating over all sorts of possible
ciphers games to explain a sort of toy
example here
as the consequence of three we can use
statistics on character sequences as I
was talking about before so we know
which letters belong to which works and
then lastly because we have access to
the source language we can take an
arbitrary sample of that and use that as
training data for a machine learning
algorithm so that's why I've made these
assumptions those are the consequences
and before I frame the task I'm just
gonna give you a little 101 refresher
course on permutations if you've done
computer science on mathematics you've
seen this all before but from a really
elementary perspective a permutation is
just a rearrangement of distinct objects
so I think people in the line the people
are all different and the order is
important who gets coffee first
for us however the permutations will
always be on letters they'll be on the
alphabet in which we write the tests and
from a more mathematical perspective a
permutation is just a one-to-one map
from a finite set to itself how do we
write them well there's different
notations there's an arrow diagram which
is perhaps most explicit but also most
bulky so things from the top map via
arrows to things on the bottom we have
an a mapping down to B B to C C back to
a and so on D remains where it is this
is of course just a Python dictionary if
you like so we can express the same
thing with slightly different notation
but the notation that's most interesting
for me and most useful later on is the
cycle notation by far the shortest and
what it means is that if a sequence of
letters is in brackets then each letter
maps to the one after it
so a maps to be B maps to C C's at the
end of the bracket so it goes back to
the beginning so in fact that green
cycle is representing exactly the same
permutation as you see in the arrow
diagram what happens to D well it's on
its own you could leave it there in a
single bracket but by convention we just
admit it so if ever you see a
permutation with a letter missing that's
because it's the identity on that letter
all right so here's a final simplifying
assumption to the problem that makes the
problem a little bit easier to talk
about but it's not it's not significant
in any statistical sense so the
observation is that in general the
ciphertext alpha
and plaintext alphabets could be
different so if your enemy is
particularly perverse they might give it
to you in an unfamiliar script like this
the cat said on the map might be in
winnings for example and you don't know
about the winnings alphabet well I'm
going to say that because we've assumed
we're doing we're dealing with the
monoalphabetic substitution cipher we
can make a simplifying assumption at
this point here so monoalphabetic
substitution ciphers mapped single
plaintext letters to single ciphertext
letters it's a one-to-one correspondence
so let's do the following pre-processing
trick to get out of wingdings land what
we're going to do is write down the
obscure alphabet in any order we please
and write down the plaintext alphabet in
any order we please we've got access to
the plaintext alphabet because by
assumption we have access to the
language in which the plaintext is
written and therefore we know it's
standard alphabet so here's an arbitrary
one-to-one correspondence here doesn't
matter what it is we could have done it
in any other order and then we're just
going to replace the unfamiliar letters
with the familiar ones so here we go I
got something on the right hand side
that I can now sort of read but it's
equally meaningless now you might say
Steve isn't that cheating and I would
say well no information has been lost we
could always reverse it back to the
obscure after that if we want and the
problem is no harder or easier
statistically but it does have the nice
simplifying assumption that we can say
the cipher texts and plain text have the
same alphabet and therefore what we're
really looking for is a decryption key
which is a permutation of that alphabet
just one single alphabet okay so now I
can finally frame the task that I'm
going to give the eventual machine
learning algorithm we're given a space
preserved mask encrypted cipher text
I'll call C we know the source language
and the name of the alphabet is a we've
got a training sample T of text from
that language not the same as the
plaintext
but from the language nonetheless and
the goal is to find the decryption key K
which we can assume as a permutation so
it's a little bit of notation I'm going
to say if we've got a decryption key and
some ciphertext then applying K to that
ciphertext which is the current best
effort to ciphertext so this K of C just
means what we think is that a ciphertext
at the present moment in
algorithm alright so we framed the
problem I told you what encryption
decryption is I've told you the
assumptions and so on let's get to the
whiteboard and sketch out a naive
algorithm and this is this is very naive
indeed it's a one-liner and it's it's
woefully under specified but here we go
so my idea my initial idea is that we're
going to iterate over all the
permutations of the alphabet until we
get the correct answer that's it so if I
had to if I had to do a coding interview
and write that down in steps on the
whiteboard it would look something like
this you got to start somewhere so why
don't we start with the identity
permutation in the alphabet a so the
thing that maps 8a be to be easy to see
leaves everything in line well then I'm
going to iterate over all the
permutations and for each permutation PI
for example here's what I'll do so if PI
of C is more similar to T than K FC is
similar to T and something's going to
happen but that's that's already a bit
computer Cody so let me unpack that into
English for you what I'm really saying
is if the new decrypted text the
decrypted text coming from my second K
PI is more similar to the training text
than the old decrypted text in other
words K of C then I'll do this thing but
another another even simpler way of
explaining that line is if pi is a
better key than K that's all I really
want to specify okay well if so what do
I do I update the key pi is better than
K so let's make K equal to PI and once
I've iterated over all the permutations
in the alphabet well I'm gonna return
this this key K which is presumably
being updated a few times along the way
all right so that's my first effort but
there are a few problems with it too to
be precise so the first problem is this
one here I've blithely said that I'd
like to eat irate over all the
permutations in the alphabet but a
typical alphabet even one that's pretty
small like the Latin alphabet in which
we write English say has 26 letters and
the number of possible permutations in
those letters is 26 times 25 times 24
and so on and that turns out to be 4
times 10 to the 26 so 26 zeros on the
end and I figured out using
- notebook then if you decrypted a
million or if you checked a million of
these keys per second it would still
take you thirteen trillion years to
iterate exhaustively over those
permutations so lovely simple algorithm
but but too naive to work in finite time
well in time you're prepared to wait so
problem number two is a semantic one
it's that we don't know what similar
means or rather we don't know how to
tell the computer what two similar texts
should look like so these these are the
two major problems with this naive
approach and the rest of my talk will be
unpacking solutions to those problems
feeding them back into the algorithm for
making it more precise and explaining
what that is but just so I can foresee
precise what these solutions are you
have a little Northstar to aim for in
the talk let me vaguely explain what
they are so the the first one we're
going to solve not by iterating over all
the permutations of a but by picking a
sensible iteration step a little bit
like the way you step update in
stochastic gradient descent in the real
case to pick correct permutations from a
from a huge possible space I'll explain
what that means in much more detail
later and then the second solution will
be similarity for our machine will be
encoded in letter sequence frequencies
okay so that mean oh and what that means
is when we glue the the two precise
explanations of those ideas together we
can build a nice machine learning
algorithm so onto the next section we're
going to do a little bit of maths and
stats that it's simple stuff so the
first idea I'll need is that of an
Engram so an Engram for me just means a
sequence of n letters that's not
interrupted by a space so it's inside a
single word so sometimes people use
adding grounds to mean words in a
sentence I don't mean that I mean
characters in words okay so for example
the cat again is sitting on the map the
one grams would just be the letters in
order and there the spaces don't really
matter at all the two grams well that's
the sequences of two letters you've got
th and then you've got H
because there's a boundary between the
enlarged the next diagram or to Graham
is LA and so on and three grams work the
same way so that's just what an Engram
is now what's what's interesting or
important about them well to give you a
sense of why they might help encoder
text in a way that's that helps you
write a machine learning algorithm I've
done a little data visualization
experiment here so this is called by
grams in the wild and what I've gone out
and done is taken a German Wikipedia
article and it happens to be a article
for cryptography and I've computed the
bigram frequencies so two grams
sequences of two letters and because
it's two grams you can arrange them in
an array where the rows of the array
correspond to the first letter and the
columns of the array correspond to the
second winner done a little bit of
pre-processing to make it 26 by 26
German has almond outs like so I've
replaced that with wall-e everything's
fine and I get something like this so
unfortunately you probably can't read
the letters in the tiles there but it's
indexed both rows and columns by at the
standard Latin alphabet and to give you
a sense of that let me just point out
that that that glowing one there is en
so it's in the ether oh and the enth
column okay where's the color coming
from well this is in fact a heat map of
a frequency matrix so the the secret
matrix code in the sense of the film as
well behind this picture is a 2 byte as
a two-dimensional array with real number
entries and I've just got a heat map
which says that yellow is really hot and
therefore high real number and blue is
really cold therefore low so that I'm
going to sort of suggest that this is
kind of like a fingerprint for the
German language it tells you that en for
example is a really common diagram as is
ER which is the other yellow one there
and almost all the other biomes don't
appear most of the time at all so it's a
highly non uniform distribution and very
specific so let me expand upon that a
little bit more diagrams are kind of
like fingerprints for natural languages
in the sense that they're stable within
a language that doesn't matter which
sample of text you pick from within
German
example but they also vary between
languages so German and English diagrams
are quite different let me let me give
you a an illustration so I won't label
the rows and columns of these bigram
heatmap matrices just yet but I want you
to observe that on the left hand side
the top and bottom matrices are visually
quite similar if you squint your eyes
they're almost indistinguishable and on
the right hand side they're quite
similar as well you see that those
you've got those two yellow tiles
repeated but not quite the same so
they're similar because the left-hand
matrices come from two english sample
text and the right-hand matrices come
from two German sample texts we're kind
of like fingerprints or rather they're
different but the the rows are similar
to each other within each column even
though the two sample texts are quite
different so I have taken the Wikipedia
entry for ancient Rome in both languages
for the top row and a Wikipedia entry
for cryptography in both language
certain bottom row so they're two very
different thermal very different texts
and nonetheless you have this similarity
of by grandparents which I find quite
fascinating
I'd never visualized this before until
they are prepared this talk and in fact
I wrote the algorithm before I I did
this visualization it's kind of neat all
right so what's the what's the punchline
here why am i showing you these pretty
heat maps well I'm going to suggest that
proxying a text by its matrix of bigram
frequencies is a really good feature
ization for a machine learning algorithm
so in practice it'll be the
two-dimensional arrays of real numbers
behind these things but if I'm going to
do that because my problem is to decrypt
a mask cipher and because a mask cipher
is essentially a shuffling of the
alphabet I'd better know what happens to
the matrices when I shuffle strings by
exchanging letters with each other so
let me let me show you what happens
using an example the cat is again on the
map and to simplify things I've taken as
my plaintext alphabet exactly those
letters that occur in the plaintext
there are nine distinct ones all
together and they
he looks like this so we see that a maps
to H and C maps E and so on so the
question is what happens to the diagram
matrices when you apply a mask
encryption let so let me just work out
the one on the left hand side 9 by 9 the
top right hand corner that that yellow
thing there is 80 which is as you might
expect because it occurs in caps a turn
map 3 times much more than anything else
and what I'm going to do now is just
work out the bigram matrix for the
cipher text on the right-hand side thing
we can't read okay and I'm going to show
you that it's really just a shuffle of
the original matrix and what I mean by
that was first of all just notice that
it's it's the same set of colored tiles
just rearranged right you're I can see
that straight away but it's a shuffle in
a more precise sense that in that it
comes from the permutation and let me
explain with an example
you might have seen this already
actually but let me focus just on one
tile to illustrate what's going on so
this a T which occurs most frequently in
the plaintext here
well that maps over to H n that's the
yellow thing on the right hand side well
why is that it's just because a maps to
H like the key tells us and team FS n
it's just no surprises there but what
that means is that the 8th row has been
mapped over to the H row on the right
hand side and the teeth column to inter
column in other words the rows and the
columns are being shuffled exactly
according to the permutation and that
kind of makes sense because a mask real
Able's the by grams just by shuffling
the letters and so that's going to have
the same effect of relabeling the rows
and columns of the matrix and when you
write them back out in alphabetical
order you're applying exactly the
permutation that the K gives you okay so
I've I've dumped a lot of information
about permutations and engrams onto you
now so I just want to spend this slide
kind of summing up as to why we want to
use a bigram matrix you know machine
learning representation here so the
first thing I said is maybe we could
represent a text by its matrix of
backgrounds and the second thing I
pointed out was this fingerprint slide
that two texts from the same language
have similar representations even if the
text themselves have nothing to do
each other so what's the punchline here
in a machine-learning context I'm going
to use that particular fact these
similar representations in this
particular context so I'm going to say
well that means that the plain text and
the training texts have to have similar
diagram matrix representations right
because by assumption they come from the
same language someone has told us that
the cipher is in English so I go out and
I download any Wikipedia English article
I want I still can't read the cipher
text but I know whatever that plaintext
is it's in English and so it's matrix of
diagrams will have to resemble the
matrix of diagrams of the training text
it's really important and then the last
thing I told you was well mask
encrypting your plaintext is really just
letter substitution and that corresponds
to row and column permutation of the
corresponding background matrices so I'm
going to illustrate that here by just
saying well the ciphertext is some
rearrangement in this case I've just
taken a rotation or something so we're
trying to pick a permutation of rows and
columns which take us back to something
looking like the training text which
will therefore by the first row be
something looking like the plaintext
that's the chain of reasoning here so
I'm really interested in this shuffle P
of the rows and columns of the cipher
text matrix so in other words decryption
is exactly the process of finding and
applying that permutation T ok so in
order yeah okay so take this step back
with the naive algorithm solution I
suggested they would there were two
problems right the first problem was
that there are way too many permutations
to iterate over exhaustively and the
second problem is that it's not clear
what a similar cipher and by touch
cipher and training text should be to a
computer so I've addressed the
similarity problem by saying we can turn
text into bigram matrices and see if the
bigram matrices are similar as a proxy
for the similarity of texts
that's tick that's why I did all the
heat maps but I still haven't told you
how we solve the exhaustive iteration
problem and in order to do that I'm
going to have to give you three simple
facts
about permutations so we understand them
a little bit better and then that'll
tell us at the end what our kind of
atomy is in the permutation world in the
same way that if you are looking at
whole numbers at integers the atoms are
sort of prime numbers because every
every number is made up out of multiples
of those I'm going to find out what an
atom is in the permutation world so
that's the term hitting here so here are
the three facts every permutation is a
product of cycles so if if you don't
know exactly what that means because I
haven't said what a product is I'm going
to tell you by example so here's a
rather complex looking permutation on
six letters except that it's not as bad
as it initially looks because if I
highlight it like that you can see that
a and D have been exchanged among
themselves so BC D sorry BCE and F must
be doing their own thing as well and it
turns out if you write this in my
favorite cycle notation you get Ad as a
cycle no surprises there but you can
tease out that B maps to e e maps to see
C maps to F in EPS F max back to B and
the important thing to note there is
that both of those things in the
brackets are cycles you're just shifting
things along until you get to the end
and then you go back right so I've taken
this complicated thing and I've written
an hour as a product of cycles let me
suggest an analogy that will help you
sort of grip onto that if permutations
are like the world of all matter in
physics then cycles are kind of like
molecules and they're really saying that
matter can always be broken down into
molecules right the second thing that
I'd like to point out is that every
every cycle is a product of
transpositions or swaps and a
transposition just means swapping two
letters so for example a and D swap
that's it okay and that that as a in
metaphorical terms is kind of like
saying every molecule can be broken down
into atoms so I told you all matter is
made of molecules all molecules and made
of atoms so all matter is made of atoms
it's one of those Greek philosophical
syllogisms and for us that means every
permutation is a product of
transpositions so let me let me just
illustrate that cycles can be broken off
into transpositions
which is maybe the hardest thing that
I've suggested here
by an example and then I'll suggest how
the example generalizes so taking a
simple example on just four numbers it's
the cycle 1 2 3 4 you send 1 to 2 2 to 3
3 to 4 back to the start and I'm
asserting it can be broken up in the way
on the right hand side so permutations
just by convention are multiplied from
right to left
so what the right hand side is saying is
that first of all you swap 1 & 4 and
then swap 2 & 4 and then you swap 3 & 4
let me show you that this really works
with a picture so firstly let's just
apply the whole thing so you take the
sequence of letters 1 2 3 4 play the
cycle permutation and it just moves
everything along there's no surprises
there
but secondly why don't I from right to
left just to play all the swaps that I
said well the tile item in green so
they're more visible you've got 1 being
swapped with 4 then 2 being swapped with
4 and finally 3 gets swapped with 4 and
you can see that we get right back to
where we started so you might say well
you know I don't quite trust you Steve
you're a sneaky mathematician you might
have picked an example that works better
doesn't generalize but the interesting
thing is this is a particular pattern
that really does generalize because
let's let's look at the shape of that
decomposition there so swapping one with
four is really saying let's swap the
first in the last name whatever those
two things are then swapping two is four
is like the second and the last thing
and in the third in the past and so on
and so on
so genuine pattern there and that that's
what I'm writing here in this general
notation is saying first of all you swap
a MS ed and then the inner Zed and so on
really works okay so I think that's kind
of neat about permutations but the take
home for us is that these transpositions
these swaps are like the the atoms of
the permutation world so what that means
is if you have like ten people in a row
and you want to get any rearrangement of
them you can always do it just by
swapping two at a time and what we're
going to do then is take these
transpositions and then apply them to
our existing decryption key to just make
it a little bit different every time
just a little bit different and then
we'll check it and we're guaranteed that
we could always get to the right answer
because of this decomposition because
you can always build things
swaps that's what we're going to do here
so let me with all of those facts
outline the algorithm it's a machine
learning algorithm so I'm gonna need
some notation and I'm gonna need to tell
you what an objective function is that
me you assemble all of that first but
first I'll remind you of what the task
is we formulated that a few slides ago
but we're given some masks encrypted
cipher text C we know the source
language and we know what the alphabet
is it's all known we also have access to
training texts and then the job is to
find a permutation of that alphabet and
that permutation will be the decryption
key all right so first of all our tart
the formulation of the task gives us
some input data so that's the alphabet
the ciphertext in the training text
don't noted thusly
a little bit more notation K as I
suggested is the decryption key I'm
calling it current here because it'll
keep getting updated in a for loop in
the algorithm and it's sort of our best
guess at each stage that's all that
means
remember K apply to C is therefore the
current to cypher text and the only
mutation there is M and F which are by
ground count and by ground frequency
matrices so there will be two by two
arrays and for any pair of letters
they'll have an entry telling you how
frequently those letters occur in either
the decipher text or the training takes
okay so here's the objective function
alright it's a bit it's a bit
intimidating at first so it's saying
I'll read it out and then I'll break it
down it's saying we're going to take the
product over all pairs a and B in the
alphabet that's that a cross a thing
there of the empirical frequency coming
from our training text of that
particular diagram ^ the number of times
that bigram appears in the current
leader ciphertext it's a whole mouthful
and it's not quite clear what's going on
at first glance so I'm going to going to
take it more slowly so that thing there
is the empirical probability of a B so
it's it's saying how many times do you
expect that to occur based on your
training data and that thing there is
the number of times that occurs in the
currently decipher tape
so let me let me give you an example
let's imagine where most of the way
through the decryption process so it
knows already that 80 is quite a
commonly occurring diagram so we've got
three we have three copies of 80 we'll
suppose and the question is what's the
likelihood that those things occur in
the current leader ciphertext well 80 is
a pretty commonly occurring background
so let's say it occurs 5% at the time
well naively you might say well let's
just multiply five percent times five
percent times five percent and that will
give me my 0.05 to three and that's
color-coded there the way it is to give
you to suggest that the 0.05 is the FT
has a pretty clear example and this
integer is the number of times it occurs
in the currently decipher text the green
thing there okay now you might say well
you know are you really allowed to
estimate the number of times these
diagrams occur in this naive way just by
multiplying together doesn't that
suggest they've been independently
sampled from some distribution and the
answer is no I can't do that
legitimately because for example if you
consider the by grams in the wood right
the first of them is th and the second
is 80
so really the second letter of the first
by gram is constraining what the next by
a gram can be so can't be an independent
distribution so this is in a sense an
artificial assumption but nicely happily
for us it turns out to be good enough to
do some warning on so that's that's why
I have this this thing has the shape it
does okay so in other words if you
multiply the bottom thing to the power
of the top thing you get the empirical
probability of that many occurrences of
that particular diagram the ciphertext
and so the whole product is just the
probability that each by gram occurs as
often as adults in the decipher text in
other words it's a likelihood function
all right so let me just walk you
through the algorithm and then we're
we're done tiny bit more notation so T
is going to be a transposition one of
those two letter swaps and PT is a
permutation matrix corresponding to that
transposition I haven't defined what
that is so I'm going to show you with a
picture
so the identity if you apply a
permutation to the identity matrix to
its rows and in this case we're swapping
the second and third row because it's
the permutation to three then you get
what's called a permutation matrix
that's all that thing is there so K
probe is the provisional decryption key
it's just a separate variable that I
keep to make sure that I only update the
actual provision see if I get a better
answer and R is the number of
repetitions
in my Falak so I'm going to start off at
the beginning by just sending K equal to
the identity and then I'll compute the
frequency matrices F T and F KC and then
this time instead of looping over all
the permutations which is sort of
impossible I'm going to for each
permutation in range are just choose at
random a swap and I'm going to set my
provisional key equal to that swap times
the existing thing and then what I'm
going to do is say okay like has that
improved has that made my ciphertext
more likely and that's what this this
matrix multiplication does here and in
order to decide if it's made it more
likely I need to compute the new
likelihood function and the old
likelihood function and compare them and
if it's more likely then I update
everything and you do this whole at a
times and then you return your key and
that's the algorithm so I thought I
would end with the demonstration I wrote
a little bit of code to implement this
so here we are here and you can download
yourself and play with it if you want so
let's clear the screen
first of all okay so what I got here is
a little bit of plain text and a little
bit of training text so the plain text
is taken from the New York Times it's
just an article about an Argentinean
astronomer who by accident observed a
supernova while looking through a
telescope that's turned out so that's
the thing that's being encrypted and
then the training text here is someone
doing a census of penguins in Antarctica
using dry
so that's what it's learning on alright
so I've got a little demo script that
does everything all at once and what
it's doing is its encrypting the
plaintext with a random key and then
storing the ciphertext and then it
passes down the pipeline just a
ciphertext but not any information about
the plaintext and it says hey use the
algorithm I just explained to try and
guess so the algorithm kind of works but
not always it's it's not a great
algorithm it's maybe three out of five
types so we might have to try it a
couple of times but there's a nice
visualization along with it okay there
we go
so he's a little like ASCII art heat map
of the updated by guy matrices here and
it's it's sort of like it started off
with with rubbish there and it's got to
Boop the star which should be broom and
star so let's let's kind of try again
okay here we go okay so it seems to good
at writing and probably get it wrong
again sort of settled on two things so
on and so on so that's just let's just
straight up - with numpy there's no
other machine learning libraries there
it's just it's doing exactly the thing
that I was explaining in the talk thank
you very much for listening
[Applause]
there
yeah any questions start with mati hi
yeah thank you very much for that
no this this reminds me so much of the
off like good-turing smoothing and the
way they Turing in the Second World War
solve the Enigma code is that like am I
completely off on that or is there like
a clear relation to that yeah I don't
know any of the details about how how
the bombs worked all I know is that the
code that he was solving is much much
harder than this so the German I mean it
was translating English German like
decrypted German into unencrypted German
but well yeah I guess the point about
Enigma is that it's a much much harder
cipher than the one the one I was using
so I think like the combination space is
like orders of magnitude more difficult
yeah I was just wondering about the neat
terminal visualization of the background
matrix
yeah that something you wrote just for
this yeah yeah I think there's a there's
something called Co LR like color
terminal in Python so I should have
given some some attribution to the the
color authors if they have to be present
yeah so it's it's just a silly little
did I ask you out
and so thanks for the talk this is super
fun well is there anything documented
even Iran failed attempt but on applying
something like this to the Voynich
manuscript they yeah so that that's what
got me interested in it to start with I
felt like God is for his friendship
things really cool but of course it's
it's it's like way harder than this so
there is a literature of people in the
last thirty years or something trying
and failing to defeat the Voynich
manuscript with methods like this but
the data and I think the most recent one
was like one or two years ago so there
was a couple of guys that wrote a paper
in which they sort of suggested they
might have decrypted one sentence from
the Voynich manuscript and and explained
a whole bunch of stuff there but my
sense was that the community of people
who really understand this stuff were a
bit skeptical and kind of said like if
you've really got it you should be able
to tell us what the whole thing is and
not just one one sentence yeah so so do
you have a way to measure the success of
this not empirically by running it on a
corpus but actually theoretically and
the reason I'm asking is this is helpful
in to sort theoretically in the worst
case because it seems like graph or memo
a graph a homomorphism or one of those
graph isomorphism right so I assume it's
like computationally hard but you
dealing with particularly type of text
and so on is that any kind of theory
that can be done analyzing this that's a
great question um I don't know like I
for me this is just an empirical project
so I imagine it would be really hard you
know you'd have to all sort of balance
that would depend on the amount of
training texts you had have to assume
that it came from a certain kind of
distribution like there's a whole lot of
statistical assumptions you'd need to
make about the shape of your training
data in order to kind of nail down the
problem enough I imagine in order to
prove something rigorous about it so
that like a fascinating question that
wasn't wasn't part of my
addicted all unfortunately yeah okay so
thank you very much Steven thank you
thank you
[Applause]